so here we are actually so Wesley
welcome to the show the game finished in
the draw with Anish giri important game
like every game in this event of course
so can you tell me I was wondering to
which point you knew the theory let's
switch first all to your game because
we're still analyzing Leon's position so
well I actually knew around until move
11 or move 13 I couldn't remember
exactly but first of all I didn't know
that Anish was gonna go for this line
because he's been playing the Italian
yes during the entire rapid and then he
went for the end game the other day
but yeah but similar ideas with Knight
to five I think he likes this one I mean
it's typical for this positions of
course but he brought his Knight also to
F5 and that one yeah but an interesting
game I mean I play this with both colors
and always seems when the Knight gets to
F5 white gets a pleasant position but I
wasn't sure I was thinking for a long
time for A4
guess the engine doesn't like it so
maybe what I played this okay mhm I
don't know A4 yeah maybe what I played
was good then because yeah actually I
thought E4 was the way to go sacrificing
a
pawn uh uh but uh yeah I guess black is
just fine here because I have the bishop
there so if whenever the position opens
up I have counter chances like Anish
told me he was considering D4 for a
while and guess black has several good
responses I guess A4 like we looked at
this position briefly right after the
game and it seems black as counterplay
cuz uh the queen is not getting trapped
yeah that's what I'm trying to figure
out like you to Knight E3 you know
already started to see some ideas you
know with Knight E3 yeah and now black
is lucky to have Knight E5 Knight E5 yes
okay just to to be sure that we're okay
let and then I can chop off the Knight
then now the queen is face yes yes so uh
but uh at the end he didn't play this
yes he played Bishop B3 yeah he didn't
like the move Bishop E3 because it seems
a bit slow and now he can never play D4
D4 I thought thought white could go A4
also for to play in both
wings and then I was calculating
bishop and then play some something like
that and now I have to figure out how to
defend the C7
Pawn but I guess it's no
problem I saw you on the last for quite
a long time with uh with Anish on the
way here yeah because uh Anish is always
a great player to analyze with he's got
a lot of wisdom and ideas he always is
so was he afraid of any any moment at
any moment what did he think about his
position yeah I guess he wasn't very
happy here black of the bishop there yes
uh I don't know but the position got
real close like I'm not sure how good
this engine is but I also made a mistake
like I played
the what this stupid engine like
giving yeah don't really better black
better I'm sure that you uh your
knowledge is better than this engine so
don't pay that much attention to it yeah
like keeping almost minus one but I
don't think yeah maybe here maybe take a
knight B8 I don't know oh in this
position this moment yes so you always
want to get to D4 right with your knight
the question is at which moment and when
or B4 yes I think I was going to play B4
first but then I play G6 anyway was very
stupid like Bishop Knight Knight E3 and
I guess it's still a draw but
uh yeah I guess I guess we I guess it's
just a the well but maybe here you don't
allow white to have a file I don't know
makes any difference like Bishop D7 then
maybe you keep and white has no plans
because if he like he has no real plans
like here I could play Bishop D6 or
defense seven yes mhm yeah I guess like
I played this structure many times in my
life yeah so it's
usually uh I know black has a bishop
here but at the same time no way to
open the position so easily yes yeah but
uh well I mean I didn't want to lose on
a Thanksgiving Day so this this is of
course something we don't like to do yes
yes so Happy Thanksgiving to everyone
yes also Happy Thanksgiving for you
Wesley so I guess it's
a pretty solid game but uh somewhere
here around here there was one moment
where you remember that you started to
move your knight on B8 maybe instead of
it you could have chosen another road
through no no still we had Rooks maybe
yes maybe you could could go through f8
but I was wondering if you were afraid
he will play Bishop H6 trying to
exchange the the Knight to the bishop or
something like that I mean the same idea
but again you keep the a file oh that's
true maybe yeah but I was very confused
at this point why Anish Play Bishop C1
to E3 I can just Rook A1 oh okay and
then I guess I have to play Bishop B7
but believe now the bishop is blockaded
like generally with D3 E4 you don't want
the bishop there okay maybe like H4 but
I guess just Queen here and uh black is
pretty pretty solid like uh I was a bit
worried during the game My Bishop could
turn bad the light scored but I guess
some point yes mhm it's uh nothing real
because white needs to get F4 in and
it's just very difficult for for him
without allowing I always have
counterplay on D3 at the very end let's
say could you try instead of closing the
position to push somewhere G4 instead of
like H4 trying to I mean at the very end
like the moment you somewhere here you
know in descending I mean only you have
this idea to to open the position I'm
very surprised why he didn't play G4 oh
he had this chance I guess he he was
yeah I guess it's I guess he didn't
maybe maybe he didn't wanted to have
this H Pawn H5 h for yeah Mak King is
very
vulnerable yeah no I
think maybe Magnus would have won this
back just kid I think it's just
completely drawn
because uh if you use a stronger engine
even a slightly stronger it will give
all zeros yeah most probably yes but I
mean also my Bishop has no way to yeah
but I was surprised like
uh King if
one yeah I guess it's just nothing I
thought he was going to go G3 F4 like
but if he plays G3 then maybe he gets
some
weaknesses mhm like uh for example if I
get this
position then now maybe I get some some
Bishop D7 yes comes out mhm yeah looks
interesting and the Knight is badly
placed but
uh but uh with this Pawn structure I had
a very similar Pawn structure with my
game against Magnus in Norway this year
mhm and uh yeah also what white one
structure was imp pregnable yeah and
that so Wesley one more draw what to do
with this event will anyone deliver a
point you know will score what do you
think well I'm told I said before the
game I'm very happy I won't finish last
place for
sure okay but uh I mean in all honesty I
I wish Yan Kristof a speedy recovery I
hope his sickness is not too not to
extreme uh it's just the way the world
is these days you know it's like
everyone's getting sick new new diseases
pop up left and right I saw in the news
the other day that there seems to be
some new respiratory disease in China
again mhm but uh yeah health health is
much more important then chess I wish
him well yeah of course and ever
happened to you that you had you were
sick during the tournament and you had
to play when you really didn't feel
well um nothing that serious fortunately
like I generally finish my tourament I
think I withdrew twice in my life from a
tournament but they were open
tournaments maybe I withdrew two or
three times but it's more of fatigue M
like brain fatigue uh you didn't play
well in this events so sorry you didn't
play play well in those events yeah like
I played in air Air flat open mhm back
in the 2011 one example okay I think
2011 yeah 2011 and then I had to
withdraw after six games just I I
couldn't play I played in W before that
and uh it was too much so uh it's more
like brain fatigue like I also had to
play sometimes when I had a cold or in
the India Olympiad last year I wasn't
feeling well for the first two rounds
but fortunately it wasn't uh I I I
didn't have any serious diseases
yet that's good let's hope everything
will be fine with Wesley I'm I'm not of
old
the in the tournament okay thank you so
much all the best of luck for you Wesley
into the next rounds and we'll go back
to the studio to yes Jo and Peter thank
you anasia and